I'm not gonna mince words about this I
want justice for that tiger Westworld
season 2 episode 3 virtue a Fortuna I'm
sure I butchered that that accent really
badly so my apologies there so spoilers
if you couldn't tell just from the intro
bit so this was there's some interesting
wrinkles going on here I we get our
first like serious look at another park
other than you know the way other than
West world you know we get a look at
basically I think it's like British
colonial India Jentezen odd well that's
funny I was gonna say that's an odd
choice except that if you'd trail on
from from you know the idea of of West
world you know people coming in getting
to fill certain roles like if you wanted
to basically take on the role of the
British people yeah it was a nice place
to be if you don't mind being an
unscrupulous bastard but the guest it
seemed to in really enjoy being
unscrupulous bastards in this park so I
guess it works so that was interesting
seeing a bit more of that seeing where
things are starting to break down and
bleed over a little bit which came back
at the end cuz looks like we've we're
finally looking to pay off a little bit
of us having seen samurais at the end of
the first season oh we got more made
this time which is good more maids
always good I'm really enjoying her and
Hector the the two of them together are
just there they have a great chemistry
I've really enjoyed sort of the insight
we got on the writer who she's dragging
along who was a character I really
didn't like in the first season but he's
the dynamic they've got him working and
now works better and he seems to be
gaining a little bit of depth as we like
get some insight into how stuff has gone
on in his own life influenced the
storylines that he was writing so that
was interesting on him and also his his
frustration at Hector having broken from
his original
his original programming being you know
getting really angry at him you're not
supposed to have love for anybody but
Isabella like getting genuinely upset by
that and then Hector getting even more
upset that this little twerp would dare
to think that he could control him and
also their uh their other friend from
the end of last season's back the one
with wow she's got two arms again but
one of them is obviously a replacement
and feelings his back Felix and um
slightly more skeevy tech guy whose name
I can't remember but I'm also glad isn't
dead yet because well he wasn't great he
also you know he he was not one of the
really questionable and sleazy and like
uh gross tech guys from the first season
I'm glad they appeared to all be dead
but this guy was he oh he was kind of a
bumbling like aw man so I'm really
liking like the little little crew that
Maeve's built up and I'm really gonna be
curious to see where that goes
watching things play out with Dolores it
is interesting what right now I'm giving
it the benefit of a doubt because the
this.l of this aspect runs the risk of
just being inconsistent writing but
right now I'm giving it the benefit of
the doubt because I'm liking how there
seems to be at odds the degree to which
the hosts are able to break away from
their original programming and how much
of that still hangs on and is driving
their actions including Dolores because
you know for all her you know having
been basically the original one to break
free and and forge her own thing when
confronted with what she is programmed
to believe is her father that triggers
something so she's still not totally
free of this of this programming and of
these dictation 'he's from people that
she is now trying to friggin kill and I
find that interesting and I honestly the
the scene between her and Abernathy it
it chokes me up it didn't get full on
but it did choke me up because it it
felt very much like like trying to have
a conversation with somebody with
dementia you know some some
back-and-forth of just not getting
through and then it's like the clouds
part and they're there and you can
engage on a level that that you thought
didn't exist anymore and then almost as
fleetingly it's it's gone and I think I
don't know how deliberate that Eve
occasion would have been but it
certainly rang that Bell for me and it
made it a very powerful very believable
emotional moment because that that rang
very true to me based off some of my own
experiences so that that worked really
well which is good because if it didn't
work than some of her reactions towards
like when she sees them you know taking
Abernathy that might have made me go no
don't buy it but that scene worked so
well she played it so well that yeah
yeah I was on board and I bought it I am
still trying to figure out the lures to
some extent in terms of her trying to
decide who does deserve to live and who
should be dying because at least so far
as I think I understand her goals it
does seem like she is weakening her own
position you know in terms of like
talking this commander and his army into
fighting for her and then turning on
them I feel like I need to understand
what it is she's really after a little
bit better for to be sure that that
actually pans out which again if they
don't pan that out properly then it just
comes across as them trying to make her
generically untrustworthy villainous
crazy I don't know so I'm hoping there's
gonna be a little bit more rhyme and
reason to that then I I feel like there
currently is
Oh Bernard I'm I'm finding him really
really intriguing at this point as a
character as he's just trying to suss
out what's going on and and at this
point having an understanding of what he
is I find it makes him very interesting
I really I feel for the guy a lot
because he is sowing over his head and
he knows it
what else we got Tessa Thompson that
whole end of things that still the
weekend for me not because of her she's
very good but the whole we need to get
Abernathy out of the park and the
military response to the uprising of the
hosts are the elements that I kind of
inherently have the least interest in I
understand why they're there well I
understand what the military response is
there I'm still not sure I understand
why the trying to get Abernathy and
whatever code is embedded within him out
is there I'm still like but I hope and
so far they haven't over run the
narrative and I really hope they don't
because pretty much everything else I
find way more interesting I find Maeve
and her crew and her quest more
interesting I find Delores and her goals
and trying to understand them a lot more
interesting I find the man in black who
didn't show up this episode but he's
still awesome and his whole thing way
more interesting and yet that's easily
the the like at best the fourth probably
possibly because I might be forgetting
some stuff the fifth or sixth most
interesting story element chorion oh I
do have one thing that I put this on a
wish list for down the line I really
hope that at some point this season we
get a native character that is a proper
character and isn't just the painted
warrior savage like I write right now
they do have from a writing perspective
they do have the the excuse that these
this is probably how the the story
creators at West world would have made
the natives to be you know for the sake
of the narratives that they were doing
so there is kind of a meta excuse as to
why they can get away with that but I
feel like at a certain point that
becomes like how you know the the excuse
in Game of Thrones for how much rape
there is become well Westeros is a real
misogynistic society what are you gonna
do like well at a certain point like
once you've established that at a
certain point if you keep going back to
that and that becomes overly prevalent I
feel like you can't just blanket and go
well that's just how it is here I'm like
okay yeah but we know that you're not
telling us anymore by showing that over
and over and over again and I it's not
at that level yet with the with with the
native I was gonna say characters I
haven't been proper characters at this
point but if we don't get somebody who
feels like a proper character and isn't
just a danger something for other
characters to be afraid of or watch out
for or shoot then I'm gonna I'm gonna
start to get annoyed at that because
even if you can come up with a narrative
justification that still feeds a very
harmful stereotype of the of the savage
American native and we don't need we
don't need more of that you know I'm not
saying we need to do the the noble
savage cliche instead because that's its
own you know can of worms but you can we
can we get a proper character out of
these guys the Sena they just keep
showing up to be like the boogeyman and
yeah that that is that is starting to
bug me it's not again it's not a problem
yet but if we don't get like a proper
character out of this lot yeah that that
I'm gonna have a legit complaint on that
one I think oh the other thing I found
really interesting it was really clever
with with Barnard and I'm really sorry I
forgot Tessa Thompson's character where
they basically lure away one guy and
then reprogram like mmm like spike his
virtue spy
he's got his uh his gun-slinging ability
and then just set him back so that all
of a sudden the horrible things he was
about to do he sees his his men getting
ready to do those he's like oh no that's
really good that's really clever and
that's a that's an intelligent way for
people who have like this one very
limited resource to figure out a way to
to get around these guys because they
think if they can get them they can
rework them a bit but you know that's
that's just that's just using what you
have really well which is the kind of
solution to these sorts of problems I
like you know just smart application of
the few things that you have to your
advantage so think that's about it I'm
expecting we'll get more man in black
next episode since he was absent this
one so I'm looking forward to that and
yeah there's there's a lot that is
intriguing me like I said like I said a
couple of points I'm seeing I'm seeing
the pitfalls I'm seeing where the show
could could dip or it could fall into
some holes at least in terms of what I
would prefer to have from it but for the
most part still going good still going
strong so that is Westworld episode 3 of
season 2 have you seen it what do you
think about it hope you did I talk
spoilers whatever your thoughts are drop
them down in the comments let's talk
about it there's all the stuff to do
such as support me on patreon try and
help make the show better like subscribe
and Twitter and podcasts at least for
all that stuff's in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]